did you know that your pantry can double
as a medicine cabinet
huh yeah it's true look no further than
your own kitchen to find the healing
power of
food now you wrote the book food can fix
it what is the latest science between
what you eat and how you feel
i gotta say when you walk into a grocery
store you're walking into a pharmacy
that is how powerful those foods are
i've learned more about food and
affecting our health since i started the
show
then all my years practicing medicine
because we never taught it so
when you ignore food and ignore what it
can do for you you fall prey to all
kinds of ailments impact
one thing we don't talk about publicly
enough is the fact that your
bodily health that's driven by your food
your obesity diabetes high blood
pressure
those are the major risk factors for
dying of covet the fact that this is
medicine in your pantry
is just amazing i mean what is it about
these beans and i know we're both big on
the blue zones
oh yeah for sure i love dan buettner's
work with those blue zones because they
completely organize why it works but
numbers on it but beans
are inexpensive they're beans right
they're great source of protein they
come in cans
let's go through this chickpeas have
selenium in them and there's a your
lipid panel the way the fats are carried
in your blood
is impacted by that so something called
triglycerides which is one of the blood
tests you'll get back is a classic thing
that will improve
if you're eating chickpeas uh-huh oh so
the chickpeas will improve that
yes it improves your triglyceride levels
lentils are interesting because they
have folate in them
mm-hmm employees have lots of b vita
it's a b vitamin hugely beneficial for
the brain a lot of our neurotransmitters
that allow our brain to process the
world around us which by the way
distresses us
the more you can find answers to your
problems the less stressed you are so
you need folic acid to do that
lentils are rich in those and the black
beans have lots of fiber in them which
is
great great in fact all these are for
your blood sugar and
instead of sugar cinnamon is a great
hack because cinnamon will stabilize
your blood sugar and this is in your
pantry
your pack didn't cost anything so in
your tea or your coffee even what
it gives it a sweet sort of exotic taste
but there's no sugar in it
so add cinnamon because what are your
your cooling herbs okay
and then also i am a big tumeric nut and
that is also in your pantry don't spill
that on you what are the benefits of
turmeric one of the best antioxidants
anti-inflammatory that you can get but
i'm gonna give you my best tip of all
since you're right in front of them
see these see these almonds you got yeah
you uh yes
i'm going to come back to your herbs in
a second but what i do with my almonds
first of all everyone should soak their
nuts
men and women so i'm sure they should so
you soak the nuts for a couple
hours the reason for that is they
actually start to germinate you're
actually allowing the proteins in them
to start to do what they're supposed to
do the enzymes come alive these are baby
trees
now you take these and then you sprinkle
cinnamon
on top of them in the bag right or
you can do or the or the turmeric you
can pick whatever you want
but i like the cinnamon put it in there
and then
shake it up and now one of the best
secrets of all
is you can walk around you're never
never hungry because if you feel an urge
to go forging through a vending machine
just take out your bag of soaked nuts
people might stare at you it doesn't
matter
and then off you go um
now can you teach me why apple cider
vinegar is so important because i see
like
jennifer aniston can't live without her
apple cider vinegar i'm like if jennifer
aniston does it i'm going to do it
so apple cider vinegar has something
called acetic acid in it
and it's very helpful in slowing down
your body's
problems with sugar so it'll actually
help you digest the sugar effectively
reduce the amount of blood sugar that
your blood system sees
at its very core if you can make it part
of a ritual that you have
and just toss it down it also helps the
bacteria of the gut so there's a reason
it's become the number one most popular
home remedy in america
i mean cheers
whoa um all right
so how can you make a yummy meal from
some of these ingredients find out
next but first renowned breast surgeon
and author of the book
breasts the owner's manual dr
christy funk is giving her advice on
what you can do
to promote good breast health which is
so
important and not something to run away
from so
take a look at this i'm so excited to
share my top
breast health tips with you today number
one
keep moving even briskly walking just 11
minutes a day
cuts breast cancer by eighteen percent
put some pep in that step
three to four hours a week and cancer
drops up to forty percent
get to your ideal body weight and stay
there forever
overweight and obese women have more
breast cancer occurrence
recurrence and death prioritize eating
fruits veggies whole grains and legumes
consuming more than 30 grams of fiber a
day from foods like beans berries and
broccoli cuts breast cancer risk in half
minimize or eliminate alcohol it's a
carcinogen that increases breast cancer
risk
however if you choose to drink have no
more than one a day
and favor red wine which has some
redemptive properties
and lastly despite all the confusing
information about mammograms we've all
heard
they do find cancer and absolutely save
lives
for average risk women begin at age 40.
i wish you and all of your viewers the
breast of health